[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Donald sake on
super excited to be talking about the
origins of humanity and technology we
have charity ever joining us on the show
hello
hello thank you so much for coming on
charity thank you for having me
it was so such a beautiful encounter
that we had in Cambridge
just around January and I learned about
your project go back fetch it teaching
about the origins of humanity and I was
immediately super excited about it like
we definitely need this in our world and
for those that don't know charity and
you were here actually visiting the Bay
Area which is why we're now able to you
were at awe and you won the award which
is now on the table we'll get to that in
a moment charity's background she's a
creative technologist storyteller
performer and research fellow at MIT
xopen documentary lab and Harvard's
Derek box Centre for teaching and
learning she explores the connection
between humanity and technology her
augmented reality storytelling project
go back fresh it explores the origins of
the human race and in a collaboration
with the Ministry of Tourism of Tunisia
she's bringing to life the ancient
mosaics of the Barbara Museum and most
recently as the winner of the 2019
nexton Prize Rising Star Award from the
virtual world society and that is the
noble prize of virtual worlds find all
the links in the bio below to our
patreon go back fetch accom as well as a
Twitter profile so huge Congrats on
winning the award and this was at the
augmented World Expo yes ah and it's
awesome that you're here and that we're
able to do the show together now one of
our favorite questions to ask are
guesses what are your thoughts on the
direction of our
I think the direction of our world is
whatever we make it and whatever energy
we put out into the universe and
whatever we decide to put our attention
and energy toward is what's going to be
amplified and brought back toward us so
it's very necessary that we keep in the
positive mindset and look at all of the
good things the good strides that are
being made and focus our intention on
what we're doing right and how we can
continue to amplify that and what would
you say are some of the most important
principles to be able to put our energy
towards connection bridging gaps
actually opening up and communicating
going deeper not allowing things that
have in the past separated us to
continue to separate us because in the
end when you come down to it everything
all of those things are actually just
illusions the interconnectedness and the
unity is that truth exactly yes all
right let's do the journey
okay so born in was but in Germany these
bodies Wiesbaden Germany until six and
then you went to Florida and the New
Mexico and then Boston for school who
were you as a kid growing up I was an
avid reader I read literally everything
constantly all the time I excelled
academically and at sports I was always
kind of a type-a personality where I
would you know put my mind to something
and then I would just go completely
overboard and get completely obsessed
with it and throw myself into it
wholeheartedly and that spanned a lot of
different ranges when I was in eighth
grade I I went from I went from self
teaching myself to calligraphy and then
that summer I self-taught myself ancient
Egyptian hieroglyphics
so just like that just kind of like a
mind that's constantly thinking about
new ways that it can stretch itself and
I would just get interested in so many
topics that at the time they seemed like
they were just so random and so all over
the place and now I'm kind of seeing
that it's my I guess my diverse array of
interests have all kind of converged
into one project that kind of is able to
encompass everything
you self-taught yourself Egyptian
hieroglyphics I did and the funny thing
about that was like I went online and
there was this like online tutorial that
you could go through and like it would
it would teach you like phonetically but
then also like the pictographic meaning
because like they can be read both ways
and I remember going through it and
thinking like okay I don't know if this
is actually true like I think this could
be teaching me nonsense and I would have
no way of knowing and so when I was in
high school I was able to paint my room
and so like I painted my room like it
was ancient Egypt and like this is still
the other room at my dad's house and
like on on the wall I wrote my name I
wrote like charity Everett's room on my
wall in ancient Egyptian hieroglyphics
so a little sister would keep coming
into my room and so when she'd come into
my room I'd be like what does that say
on the wall and like you know I'd kind
of throw that in her face so it's kind
of funny when I started kind of like
working on this project and I ended up
on the radar of the head of Egyptology
at Harvard and my dad went and took a
picture of my room and I was like okay
now I know for sure and so I showed it
to him and he actually read the
hieroglyphics in my name and I was like
okay so that means I wasn't being taught
nonsense something entered it whoa yeah
you know what a way to also get an in
into like epic people I have like
Harvard that yeah you're just like oh
I've already taught myself Egyptian
hieroglyphics Wow
okay and then um so then it was Harvard
and that's still where you're you're at
is this one more year right now 2020 as
the last year of the so I was going to
Harvard for my undergrad but then I
discovered VR and AR and I started self
teaching myself and I stopped taking
classes cuz I was just kind of like
outpacing what was being able to be
taught in schools at that point in time
and I started making my own stuff and so
right now what I have are fellowships so
I have a fellowship at MIT and I
fellowship at Harvard yeah that's that's
cool so it's like the university system
will recognize that people want to like
self teach at like their own pace
technologies and then they'll like bring
them in as fellows this is something so
it's like a different track in a sense
like more more possibility spaces are
opening up for for students to
collaborate with universities and then
what was it about like AR that you were
like oh my gosh
or just like just mixed reality in
general that you were just like this is
such an important medium that I need a
self teach myself and use for
storytelling yeah so originally I was
going to school for digital media
because I always knew that storytelling
is what I wanted to do I always knew
that the stories that I wanted to tell
were very big large and scope I really
wanted to show people let's connect the
dots between things that didn't seem
like they were connected to people even
if they happened a long time ago or even
if they're happening on the other side
of the world I'm like I was I was trying
to think about the way that I wanted to
tell this story I knew it was going to
be allegorical probably in nature I was
considering like you know graphic novels
like stop-motion animation like some
sort of interactive like I didn't
exactly know what the medium I wanted to
use was but I knew the story that I
wanted to tell and I knew that the way I
had it in my mind like it wouldn't just
work in any like form that I'd ever
really seen experience before and so
when I saw ways the origins of humanity
it wasn't as as much the origins of
humanity as much as it was kind of kind
of like reframing all of these kind of
like preconceived notions that we have
in the world like I I have a concept
that I myself kind of call like
invisible walls or invisible scaffolding
where it's like there's all of this kind
of like like when it comes to like being
a part of a society or a part of a
culture there are so many things that
come baked into it that you don't even
realize that like are these preconceived
notions that you have about like what
the world is and what life is and what
it looks like and it's it's like these
invisible walls that are up around you
and so I always was interested in using
media and especially like you know in
this form of entertainment and story to
kind of like shine lights in the cracks
of those invisible walls because it's
one of those things where like once you
actually realize the crack is there then
the whole thing kind of starts to lose
structural integrity and it gets easier
and easier to start like chipping away
at the wall but first you have to be
shown that that first crack okay
okay okay and then continue us on the
yeah I'm using the mixed reality pursuit
as well mm-hmm so um so when I first
discovered VR and air I was like oh my
god this is it this is the this is the
medium that like I can use in order to
tell this story it could be really
engaging it could connect with people on
a lot of different levels because it's
so immersive it's something that people
could really lose themselves inside it
if it were executed correctly and so
that's why I got really obsessed with
just learning as much as I could about
it and then after I felt like I've
learned enough and I'd rolled up my
sleeves and done enough I felt
comfortable enough to start working on
my own project nice okay so there's a
process of self teaching yourself easy
unity is where yourself teaching
yourself and then the also the process
of figuring out exactly how you wanted
to tell the story of finding the kind of
like cracks in a culture that needed to
shine a light in for us to better
understand reality okay and then so now
okay so now walk us through like the
reason why indigenous wisdom with this
go back fetch it with the project that
you're doing why is it so critical well
for me this project is it covers a lot
of themes but one of the main themes
that it really covers is the the idea
that like we're at a point where we're
birthing the the birthing an entirely
new medium and every aspect of it like
how how it functions and also the
storytelling aspect of it and so when I
started to think about like go back
fetch it and what this project was and
what it would mean the idea of the ethos
of it you know go back and fetch it
really started recursing throughout the
entire project and I realized that if
what we're talking about is birthing
storytelling in a new medium then we
have to go back and examine the origins
of storytelling in all mediums and if
you're doing that than what you're
really looking at is indigenous wisdom
yeah
and then um and then how then was so
then the then the moment came where you
were I'm gonna bring I'm gonna use the
augmented reality technology to tell the
story of the storage ins of humanity
then that was kind of a light bulb
moment of so um this project when I
first started it I started as a part of
an artist in residency that I had at
this place called industry lab in
Cambridge and when I first pitched this
as a project I I pitched it as being
very different in form but the the the
end goal was the same so originally I
was going to get this Sankofa image
tattooed onto my stomach and when you
scan the tattoo I was going to turn into
a visualization in the shape of a tree
with like branches growing out of my
head I mean the different branches would
represent different data points and when
you interacted with a piece of fruit on
one of the branches it was going to turn
to this animated moving a data
visualization and then I was going to
turn into this actual like personal
anecdote about how that data point
impacted me as an individual and the
data points that I was dealing with were
the global impacts of the transatlantic
slave trade and mm-hm and so I was at
first examining it from an economic
perspective just like looking at if you
look at all of the the shipping routes
that we have how they run across the
world like that actually they refined
that process through figuring out how to
effectively ship people off of the coast
of Africa to where they were sending
them if you look at the fact that the
u.s. is a first world country right now
because they ended up with hundreds of
years of free labor and how much of that
money you know went back to Europe and
you know why those the there why the you
know the British monarchy is as wealthy
as it is is because of colonialism and
even like looking at where we are now if
you look at the major export of the
United States our major export is
actually culture and if you actually
look at the origins of so much pretty
much all of American culture it all
really comes back to African American if
you look at actually the origins of
pretty much all music even if you look
back to something that you would never
even think to tie to people of African
descent is rock-and-roll music there's a
woman Sister Rosetta Tharpe who only
just
last year was inducted into the Rock and
Roll Hall of Fame and she's the inventor
of rock and roll music and there's
actually this video that you can pull up
on YouTube it's the craziest thing
you'll ever watch it's in black and
white there's this woman like this this
you know middle-aged african-american
woman who like get gets out of this
horse and carriage and she struts out
onto these railroad tracks and she picks
up an electric guitar and she just
starts going to town and this is when
Elvis Presley was in diapers
and one of the another so like that's
just something that you would never even
like think about those are the origins
but if you think about another aspect
hip-hop music or just hip-hop culture in
general right it's one of those things
that has gone completely global I had
this roommate who was from Bulgaria and
I when I was starting to tour work on
this project and he was telling me oh
yeah we have rappers in Bulgaria and
like it's one of those things where no
matter where the person is from that's
something that has that has reached
every corner of the planet like every I
don't wanna say corner because people
think that every aspect of the planet
and it's something that 100%
only exists because in the 1970s these
oppressed african-american people in the
Bronx felt that they needed to start
expressing themselves in this very
specific way so they they started you
know using music they'd always listen to
and start it like scratching it and
remix it and then started like kind of
just like rhyming on top of it like
whatever they were feeling and
expressing themselves and this is a
method of expression that has become it
becomes so woven into the bedrock of
American culture and because it's a part
of American culture and it's one of our
major exports it's become in and woven
into the bedrock of the global culture
as well and then if you think about how
much money has actually been made on
hip-hop music since the 1970s and then
you think about how how many people are
who created or originated it or the
originators of it who's actually holding
that wealth you start to actually look
at how big of a disparity it is and how
these things that people want to think
happened hundreds of years ago and don't
affect us are still the you know the did
injustice is continuing to recurse
throughout history to this day
these are where some of the dues that
the taxes that we have to pay for some
of the malevolence is that we've cost on
on the spirit of other humans on the
planet these are some of the things that
really have to be well integrated and
really honestly met like really honestly
met it's in this very complicated thing
and it's it's good that you're
highlighting so many of these for us to
see mm-hmm um okay let's let's go let's
get into this
the origins because you you're like
you're you're constantly pointing at
like the origin right this is what
you're doing you're pointing at the
origin is showing how it gets like
exported around the world and how other
people get so let's like that theme is
such a reoccurring theme and the origins
of humanity start in the African
continent yes okay this is where yes
take us take us yeah so when I so that
was that that was how I had originally
conceived the project but as I started
to research it it occurred to me that
anytime any new anyone wants to talk
about the concept of Africa they always
want to talk about it within the context
of slavery and that only takes into
account the last 500 years but what
about the hundreds of thousands of years
before that and what about the entirety
of the human race that happened before
that and so I realized that if I was
going to tell the story then I had to go
all the way back to the beginning and
then I wouldn't just be telling my story
I would be telling everyone's story and
then that's why the character of Eve
became very depersonalized for me and
she became more of this mythological you
know for mother of the human race that
everybody can kind of connect with and
get behind everyone's superheroine
origin story yeah and that's that's
right
yeah right here Eve is a woman who was
on a journey that spans the arc of human
history by accompanying her through the
quintessential struggles and triumphs
that we have built upon to this day we
explore the themes of what makes us all
human
so on so the work so we go on a journey
with Eve through what was a project
about our shared origin stories and what
makes us human yes okay so beautiful so
Eve okay so yeah teach us more about
like how'd you pick like a character to
like to be accompanying accompany
through the journey umm well so I always
realized that if you're going to tell a
story and like even though the story
always was rooted in like data
storytelling and data visualization in
order for it to actually have impact and
to connect with people what people
really care about our human stories they
care about the connection between us
they care about you know them being able
to see themselves in the data points
that are being represented or it's you
know to actually see themselves
represented in order to actually feel it
we think in stories we've always thought
in stories that's one of the reasons why
you know fairy tales are so expected you
know you can tell a kid oh don't go and
go and jump in the lake and they might
jump in the lake anyway but if you tell
the kid oh there was a little boy who
jumped in the lake and a monster came
out and got him and all this other stuff
you think that kid's gonna go jump in
the lake no because they have this you
know image in their head of what's
actually gonna happen if they engage in
that activity and so I always knew that
there would have to be a centralized
character and when I was choosing the
character it only made sense for me to
because the one of the points of this
project is to challenge a lot of
people's preconceived notions it was
like what it should be a superheroine it
should be a heroines journey you know
why is it always a hero's journey and
like what would you think about when you
when I decided to come up with the name
Eve was the only thing that came to mind
because she is the first human you know
the first human woman but then it's also
like what do people actually think of
when they think of a versus like the
anthropological evidence that we have on
what Eve would have actually looked like
based on where the origins of the human
race started and like even just in
through that I'm already starting to
like chip away at like it never would
have occurred to me that like Eve would
probably be African you know and so that
that kind of like having that limbs on
everything really informed every aspect
of what go back Fetchit has turned into
yeah there's in so many regards we are
taught in our in our egos and especially
men that have lots of power in
government and in corporations are
caught in their egos and not connected
to the spirit this mother energy that is
what sustains us to plan it and and
especially having a really true
perspective on the origins of humanity
having us and this is what projects like
this do is they give us that true sense
of our interconnectedness I'm happy that
you that you could have the woman's Eve
that takes us on the journey okay and
then we have we have a video about this
it's the first video it's of what people
using the technology and the project
augmented reality technology and they're
so excited
[Music]
so in the video you have you have you
have a you have what is a static image
of Africa and then with the humans here
on it and then what happens when they
open it up right here as Ron showing us
is that once they bring it up on their
smartphone that you can actually see
them moving the movement comes up yes
who teaches about what this what this is
like what are they using on their phone
how did you have the static image and
enable the movement be enabled on the
static image yeah um yeah so this was
quite a process and like that was the
initial tech demo that I made and that
was their reaction they'd clearly never
seen anything like that before and that
was a wonderful reaction to to
experience so basically like I I trained
I had software that I trained and I said
when you see this image do this thing
I'm what you're actually seeing is I
think that there's a slide later on that
kind of shows more about it the way that
it was actually created yeah so we
actually pull that up
so the slide that's on NDI right now and
we'll show what the style elements that
charity is talking about so Ron we'll
get that up and then okay yeah so if you
look at the top here so we actually we
shot it on a green screen um so that's
me and another person we filmed it on a
green screen so that's actually human
beings there was some animation elements
so we edit it using normal like Adobe
tools I did together with with audio or
with them those effects we told it when
you see this image overlay this on top
of it and again this was just the early
tech demo there's more and more
interactivity that's laid that's layered
into it but that was the kind of like
the way that I decided to visually
represent telling this story and even
that does deciding to go with um flat
over three-dimensional was kind of like
a throwback to where it's like okay
again we're at the beginning of the
story time technology so instead of
trying to make everything all you know
super flashy and bright and colorful and
three-dimensional and look super
futuristic like let's make it look as
old tool as possible and let's look use
those old-school tools as possible and
see you know how interesting that that
would actually look juxtaposed with such
a futuristic technical technology that's
such a funny juxtaposition it's so
rugged yeah it's the og civilization and
black and white 2d on the 2019
technology use it's very interesting
juxtaposition and then what do you do
with the the smartphone itself just do I
enter into a specific app that enables
my camera to sense the in the image and
then create that oh yeah yeah so right
now it is through an app in the future I
would it would be something that would
actually be able to work in your browser
so you wouldn't have to download an app
but currently it is app based technology
and what is the app download so you can
go to the download by going to go back
fetch it comm slash download or you can
get it there okay cool so go back fetch
accom four slash download it download it
and then where can can they still find
these up to play with around like Boston
or anywhere
they can go in they oh yeah so if you
just subscribe to my patreon account we
actually do have things that we can send
you that you can actually interact oh
that's sweet so you'll be able to see it
as it evolves as well okay like I can
get a digital image of it and then use
my use the app to Cameron and then and
physical as well and fizz I can print
them and set them up inside my something
like that something like that okay okay
cool alright and then and then you have
you have you ever that what is this that
a didn't Adinkra symbols ding krub oh so
if you go back to the last slide I can
talk more about the style elements okay
okay so image based augmented reality we
film that on a green screen made it look
like charcoal drawings but the world
itself is made out of a tinker symbols
so if you look at the Sun and the palm
tree there and actually if we could just
go ahead and play the the short video
clip of what what you actually plays
when you scan it that's the story the
story yeah okay cool alright this is the
story of a young woman
living in a time before common
[Music]
in a world made out of ancient wisdom
yeah see as you can see there those are
the two adding crumbles that actually
make up different aspects of the world
and so the world itself is going to
continue to be made up of these types of
symbols okay and so we can go back to
the style okay okay I see I see so the
Adinkra symbols are act as and that was
that was the kind of the next stages you
have these two of these two characters
even what's the is there another atom oh
cool even atom that are uh that are that
are walking and then in the next when
you see the Adinkra symbols coming up
the Sun in the palm - so what you get is
the intro into the into the world and
actually that that demo is what plays at
the end of the video like okay you watch
it but so these are different these are
Adinkra symbols and they actually
they're good knee in okay and they
embody different aspects of humanity and
they're I chose them because they're
they're contextually and also visually
very rich I'm in order to build up to
build a world on top of and it's also
again it's it's it's a it's a written
language that allowed people don't know
anything about however if you spend any
amount of time with African people you
actually see these symbols constantly
and if you go to the next slide
wait TT just about these they're so cool
like like just a few of them okay um so
this one the symbol means beauty this
symbol is a como in Tosa this one down
here yeah that one means beauty okay
this is a coma in Tosa that means like
linked hearts linking hearts together
okay this one was actually like a like a
hairstyle that royalty wore if you come
down this one ah like that was a warrior
symbol a symbol of warriors oh my god
the cutes use about the heart symbols
yeah so actually one of the one of the
main heart symbols if you go up okay
yeah yeah so this is actually one of
this Inc ofa's okay and so if you go to
the next slide
I'll tell you about this in Kofa oh my
gosh these are so cool the fact that we
can actually use symbols to communicate
that we're so far away from that now
like these beautiful symbol but I mean
what are emojis it's true yeah yeah so
it's like yeah yeah that's right
but it just seems as though like what
can like these styles yeah yeah this is
different this is like it's ru emoji set
that has yet to be yeah yeah okay yeah
so it's a go to the next okay okay so
yeah so one of these so one of the main
symbols is this in Kofa and this is
actually what the project itself is
based off of mm-hmm and it's that's the
image is actually present down there in
the trigger image and so that actually
means go back and fetch it so it means
um yeah so it means we deal with the
past before we move into the future and
the sync ofes actually the only symbol
that has or that it's the only one that
has two symbols that mean the same thing
so one of them is a bird flying forward
turned backwards with an egg in its
mouth and that definitely embodies that
concept go back fetch it yeah or you
know to protect to protect what's to
come what's you have to like you have to
look back but keep moving forward and
it's like you look back to understand
the origins right and and you look back
with the future in mind in mind yeah yes
yes yes it's so beautiful yeah and it's
actually kind of funny because the the I
realized that I was reading up on the
symbology that's used by the virtual
world Society that's actually present in
in the awards that they give me and it's
on their logo and it's kind of something
similar where it's like you know you
have this older person and they're like
lifting up a child and the child is
looking backwards but they're looking
forward and looking you know forward to
the future so it's like I guess the
nature of recursion right everything is
kind of in
upcoming full circle and coming back
yeah yeah wow this so usually when we're
born were born with such a you know
present and future but to actually be
able to love our origins as well as
understand present future so so crucial
okay so by the way how did you discover
this gun Yin symbol symbol language how
did you
so again if you spend any amount of time
with African people like you'll see it
like you'll see it on earrings you'll
see it on bags will see it on clothing
and you know you'll get to add like a
what is that like what does that mean
like where does it come from and people
are more than happy to tell you to tell
you about it and I just as I started to
learn more and more about it I realized
that you know this made a lot of sense
to be you know the anchor for the
project that I was working on about you
know connecting dots and you know
dealing with the origins of Africa and
origins of everyone and yeah yeah okay
cool cool all right
oh so yeah this is more just about you
know the the other aspects of the world
so you know the Adinkra Hannay which is
the sun a chief of the Adinkra symbols
symbol of greatness tourism and
leadership the abbe doula the palm tree
it's a symbol of wealth self-sufficiency
and vitality and so you'll continue to
see these symbols weaves throughout the
world it's the backdrop and I see this
is kind of like the so a lot of the
context of what I'm doing is like
layering different types of information
on different layers and different levels
so even though you're paying attention
to the story that's unfolding there's
other types of learning or even I'm
subconscious I don't know what's that
that term like when you're osmosis
unconsciousness mostess that's happening
I mean it's one of the reason that
symbols are so effective is because like
even if you don't have the word for what
it is like on some level you kind of
understand what's being represented and
so this being weaved into the backdrop
of the world around you as well as you
know data data visualizations being
weaved into the backdrop backdrop of the
world around you as well this is also so
grounding to nature I mean the symbols
themselves are very grounding into
nature the Sun gives us a life the trees
around us are interconnected with us
what we inhaled they exhale what they
exhale we inhale you know it's just like
such a so interconnected and I mean this
this is life this is where we come from
it's just I can obsessively rant about
the importance of this but yeah so here
the the what you're seeing what you've
been seeing clips of so far is the
prologue so I already have the next four
parts episodes of it mapped out along
the different major technological
advancements of the human story yes
so technological advancement one being
when humans discover how to make fire
and if you actually stop and think about
it and the discovery of fire was the
first major technological advancement
but it also had biological implications
actually having access to consistent
cooked meats allowed our brains to
develop faster and after that like you
know the advancement started happening a
lot more rapidly and now here we are on
simulation series talking about oxygen
company you know and the warmth the
protection from from the at night to be
able to see just protection from other
animals and stuff so many aspects of
fire just reject change the trajectory
of civilization one of the great things
to be able to do is to actually go back
and try and immerse ourselves in the
felt experience of the humans that
actually made the discoveries those some
of my favorite stuff to be able to do
and hopefully we can do that when we get
the technological capacity to run
simulations and get behind people's eyes
and stuff like that
so technological advancement to is
evolution of hunting tools yeah how we
went from using rocks to using Spears
using at laterals to bows and arrows and
bows and arrows always came right when
civilizations were really you know
starting to rise I'm agriculture like
you know evolving the hunter evolving
the the farming tools so that we were
able to do you know constant you know
stay in one space or even like evolving
to the point of hey I like eating this I
would like the idea of consistently
being able to eat this let's stop
walking around and let's put down roots
and let's actually build a civilization
and so like bite-through marking these
different phases of the human story i'm
all
so I'm also connecting human evolution
with the evolution of Technology and
showing that like technology isn't
something that happens on the outside of
us technology isn't something that
certain select people do it's something
that we've always done it's what makes
us human we would not be where we are
today if we hadn't always just
intrinsically been able to work with the
elements and the tools that were around
us to create new and better like that is
literally what technology is yeah being
born into the laptop and smartphone age
it's hard to look back and be like these
are technologies as well that helped us
advance that's a critical component of
this okay
yeah I'm so getting into the data
visualization aspects of it so um again
like the ethos of this project is about
so I have a tagline I'm challenging
consist consensus free I'm using
extended reality to challenge consensus
reality and like I said about putting
that crack in the invisible wall this
right here is a case in point about you
know a lot of people don't even realize
that the map that we've been taught our
entire lives is so drastically skewed
from anything anything more what the
world actually looks like and so this is
a visualization that actually shows how
large Africa is eleven point seven three
million square miles and all of the
countries that fit inside of it that is
the UK that is Japan that is Ireland
that is China that is that is India that
is all of Eastern Europe the US Germany
France and Portugal all fit within the
borders of Africa with room to spare and
I actually Africa is eleven point seven
three million square miles the moon is
fourteen point six million square miles
Africa is eighty percent of the size of
the moon and I actually have a
visualization here which the gif isn't
playing but I actually wrapped Africa
around the moon so you could see that
for scale for yourself to actually like
take that that's statistic in that's
something that you're never actually
shown and so one of the things that I'm
doing is I'm layering in these
interactive data visualizations and
layering in these different maps and I'm
also connecting it to documentary and
one of the things that I did is I
actually produced a documentary with the
head of geospatial mapping at Harvard
University where she kind of goes into
some of that back story about the
Mercator projection and we have that
video that's the third asset that we can
bring in right now and it was great
hearing her also mention some of the
what why we had at five hundred years
ago and what what is the updates now
that were about what the historical
purposes in the case
yes people have adopted it because
historically that's what we had to do
that's what we had to work with but
people use it in a way that it was never
intended those we use for navigation
because it needs straight lines
the problem is when taking an object
that is round
I either earth and attempting to
represent on something flat ie a map it
has traditionally resulted in
distortions either an area or shape you
start using it for other things without
explaining the distortions that are in
it then there's not enough scholarly
rigor in there it leads to the
misleading representation I mean it's
that's all there is to it as far as I
know yeah yeah and this is a very
classic thing that we're taught which is
the Mercator map in schools and then
usually if you have excellent teachers
they'll also mention that this is
distorted like Antarctica does not span
the entire bottom of the map and like
Greenland is not the same size as Africa
it's 14 times smaller than Africa and
also Africa is right on the you know the
equator going through the Sahara it's
just a it's just like a it's so massive
fitting you US China and all these other
countries in it I have a lot of other
questions that I want to ask you about
it I wanted to I wanted you to maybe
explain the trajectory of our
exploration yes absolutely and so one of
the things that I do is I I layer or I
put together different types of
visualizations so I actually have a
visualization that is the one that we
just saw about like all the countries
that fit inside of Africa but it also
mixes the human migratory patterns of
course this is according to National
Geographic there is some contention
about how people actually ended up in
the Americas that people as Japanese
people came over on boats a really long
time ago and then there is evidence that
I'm a really long time ago people came
over from Africa and ended up in South
America as well but the agreed upon
route by National Geographic and those
such scholars is that people just walked
and migrational drift happened over a
very long time
walking across land bridges the Bering
Strait over the because it's only like
50 miles or something it's so small
something like that
and it freezes over yeah yeah mm-hmm um
so yeah so this is according to the
three different you know haplotypes
they're groups that the the different
directions that they took how long they
walked when they decided to stop walking
is pretty much all that comes down to
all of these differences that we try to
act like are such a big deal it's like
literally like no your ancestors were
like this is about good I'm gonna stop
walking here and then they sat down and
put up culture and then like over time
people started looking differently and
things shifted and changed a little bit
even though if you actually start
looking into the core I was actually
just in Tunisia a few weeks ago and it
was so interesting to me as you're
walking around these ancient places
realizing how many things you look at
that and you're like wait but that looks
like that belongs in Europe and that
looks like something I would see in
Russia and that looks like something I
would see in South America and it's like
no it's just that those are the things
that kind of like got imprinted or it
got taken over when people left and then
like those became kind of like the seeds
of this new culture but everything
literally everything has the same
origins and during that stage of
exploration is like you're exploring and
then it's like yeah this is good let's
plant here and let's let's let's build
here and the interconnectedness like you
said yeah you see it across the world
like that's so important to get out of
the United States and go and engage with
other places in the world okay let's hit
yeah there's some of the cave drawings
that you have yeah so that was one of
the ideas that informed the visual style
of you know go back fetch it go back to
the beginnings of written or a visual
storytelling obviously we're talking
about visual storytelling now in three
dimensions spatially all around you what
was the very beginning of visual
storytelling it was on the walls of
caves so like let's let's mimic that in
the individual style and then the theme
of what's being presented
by Greek mythology by actually
mythologizing the character right
because like that was the way that like
if you look at the origins of like you
know all really stories it was always
these really epic stories where it was
like one larger-than-life character
who's going on this ridiculous journey
that like you know through it they
pretty much like had to they had to
atone for all of humanity's sins and
faults and and vanquish the enemy at the
end so like returning to that idea with
us like having this one centralized
woman character of Eve who's actually
going through all of these phases and
having to push forward and make that
next leap for Humanity herself and
classic film so this is actually from
George Melies a clip to the moon I don't
there's something that's not as widely
known it but everyone pretty much knows
that image but a lot of people don't
know what it's from and it was from a
film that was produced in 1912 by this
this director while he was actually a
magician he was involved with a
prestidigitation and then he was drawn
right when filmmaking came out he kept
he got really inspired by the idea of
being able to trick people's minds it
was to him it was a new type of magic
and so he was really really good at
creating these um you know he's visually
stunning like really just like magical
worlds that have like you know
simplicity and wonderment and so I
wanted to kind of recapture that that
same feeling with the look and style of
the film as well and this is more of it
like you know you would have actually
like you know hand painted things that's
the video we already watched okay mm-hmm
oh the educational potential yeah um so
that where I actually see this project
going is I see the story an art of go
back fetch it is being a portal into
this universe but once you're inside of
this universe you can follow your own
path to learning and actually connecting
the dots between other interactive and
documentary projects that people are
working on and so is serving as portals
into their worlds that they're building
out into what they're exploring and this
could continue to happen exponentially
and exponentially until you layer in
infinite amounts of information into
this whole universe
yeah their information retention is huge
yeah absolutely especially if you can
follow your own path and so yeah that's
pretty much the end of these slides oh
this is just work that I'm doing with
the Bardo museum in Tunisia they have
these beautiful ancient mosaics so this
one is actually Ulysses crash crossing
the Mediterranean all of the all of the
people on a ship have wax in their ears
he's listening but they tied him to the
post so that he doesn't so that he can
listen to the songs of the siren without
actually going into the rocks I was
standing in front of this ancient mosaic
it looks just as beautiful as this to
this day and so I'm going to be working
with them to bring things like this to
life so that people can experience it
and actually experience a lot of the
history that's in Tunisia a lot of
people don't even realize that Carthage
is located in Tunisia a lot of people
think it's located in Spain or it's
located in Italy because they had so
much trade with Rome but no it's located
in in northern Africa and there's
there's a lot there's a lot of ruins
that literally look like they're from
like a movie set from Rome or something
that you can just like walk up to and
like be around and touch and stare out
at the Mediterranean ocean and there's
just so many misconceptions about that
part of the world and so we're trying to
bridge that gap using this new
technology yeah that seems like museums
and ancient artifact archives are going
to want to leverage a great reality and
other new technologies to be able to get
people to retain the origins of where we
come from yeah it's very useful okay
yeah this was the thing that was
actually really interesting to me so a
lot of their work that they have is very
very geometric so like this here is like
obviously like early cubism like it does
this kind of like changed perspective
thing if you look at it one way it looks
like a cube if you look at another way
it looks like you know it looks like a
six-sided star you know and like when I
was looking at it and it's switching
back and forth in my mind like
automatically I thought about MC Escher
and like how this is someone that you
know a lot of people give obviously like
his work is amazing but it's like you
know this wasn't that long ago he was
making this work these people were
making this work thousands of years ago
and they were doing it and I really
inter
way they were taking three-dimensional
objects because mosaics to
three-dimensional objects they're taking
a three-dimensional concept of a cube of
you know hypercube they're taking this
three-dimensional thing they're pushing
it down and representing it in
two-dimensional in two dimensions but
with three-dimensional objects and so I
want to use AR to actually like when you
go there you're actually seeing this
stuff extruded out into the world around
you and you're seeing just how cubic it
is and how geometric it is but you're
still getting that signature mosaic
style to interact with as well just the
sheer amount of complicated time that it
took humans to do this as just as
humbling and we need to be more grateful
ya know and these are just more examples
of things that I thought were you know
visually interesting yeah there's so
many things that I want to talk that I
want to talk to you about one of them is
I'm gonna go back to you're actually
this I think this one's you're like we
can leave this one up for four for parts
of the conversation that we have now I
want to hit on this with you there's so
much of what you're doing with go back
fetch it is so critical to for us to
understand indigenous wisdom and our
origins that's so important we have um
right now we have a massive
disconnection from our origins and it's
very visible in civilizations errors and
issues that we have and the more we
connect to that spirit of nature the
more we can fix a lot of the errors that
we have consciously not bandy it's not
second order solutions but some first
principled solutions so we had a very
massive amount of trauma with what we
did with the transatlantic slave trade
that still needs to be properly
addressed and actually talked about and
healed as a planet there seems to be
there was already a Scramble for Africa
that happened in the past and it looks
like there's gonna be another Scramble
for Africa that's happening in the
future and I would like to hear your
thoughts about about that and how to
best you know be really true to the
origins of that land and true to the
native indigenous people of that land
and not economically plundering that
land geez I mean honestly leave them
alone
there's the only thing we can do to fix
the situation is just like stop please
stop meddling like that like there's if
you have caused such a mess that you
have caused that that the West has
caused this continent like there's
there's like it's it's your ear ear past
the point of like even like people who
like try or
I would say microloans I would i
microloans are a great way that you can
actually impact an effect an individual
who's trying to improve their situation
whether it's helping a person buy seeds
or help a person you know like by you
know like or whatever that they need for
this for this small thing that doesn't
mean a lot to you because twenty eight
twenty dollars to you or me or $100 or
$200 or you know like it's it's it's not
so much but to that person it could be
it could be their their economic freedom
so I think that taking things on a
really small individual personal level
I'm thinking more like you know village
and community they say you know think
look think think globally act locally
I'm having a one-on-one interaction with
another human being and helping them and
like you know they're calling it a
microloan but like if they're not able
to pay it back who cares like you gave a
hundred dollars to somebody so that they
could buy seeds so that they can you
know plant for a year and that's that's
a good thing that you did and it's
better than giving to it I think it's
one of the best things you can do yeah I
feel you on this the first part
especially it's like just stop meddling
like that same things happening with
indigenous people around the world
they've been colonized for hundreds and
even a thousand more years that have
that are now being exposed to money
they've never been exposed to money
before and now they're being exposed to
money and it's just causing a lot of
issues of the way that they connect to
spirit and so if we want to be good
stewards we need to actually work with
the indigenous wisdom and not just
plunder for economic gains and like you
said micro loans are their third and
they're nuanced in so many ways and I I
would be really wanting to see how the
US and China and all these other
countries end up like really properly
healing and working with Africa's the
median age in Africa is about nineteen
years old is completely different than
the rest of the world the rest of the
world sight like 3040 years old on
average in the countries of the world
right so again I'm you're you're talking
about Africa like it's some huge
monolith but like again Africa is big
enough to fit the majority of the rest
of the world inside of so like when
you're talking about the medium age
median age of a continent that's not
really accurate when you're comparing it
to countries um there are some countries
in Africa that have much higher median
ages there are some countries in Africa
that have lower median ages another
thing when you said that if we're going
to be good stewards I think we need to
stop thinking of ourselves or the West
as being stewards to this continent and
maybe trusting that if we stopped
meddling that they could handle things
on their own and that they don't really
need our help but if they would like it
then it should always be up to them to
describe how they would like it and for
us to just facilitate on their terms
you know
you know it's soon again it's like this
so weird like so many like effective
altruists and other people say that like
it's so important to make sure that like
some of the health issues that cause
people to have mortality rates that are
really around the world that are just
that dying so young to be able to like
go and help provide like it's set beside
treated malaria nets these types of
things are are it's so much nuance to
this and I agree with you know you're
you're on point there's there's a lot
that we can learn by understanding the
origins of humanity and understanding
our interconnectedness go back fetch it
does exactly that what is next on the
radar for go back fetch it like I'm
gonna get to experience this in like
part one of a story and then there's
yeah yeah yeah so I want to continue
building this out more I actually want
to connect this to the work of
documentarian ELISA Capay she actually
recently won the Peace Prize and the
inter the amnesty prize at the Berlin
all Film Festival this past year for a
documentary that she produced called
espera 202 Volta and it's it was between
the ages of 14 and 19 of a young woman
in Brazil when they decided that they
were going to close down a bunch of
schools this woman Marcela or this
teenager Marcela she goes through this
journey of reclaiming her African
heritage and actually becoming like a
like somebody who's actually like
fighting for her writes her own rights
and so like actually seeing echoes of
how like this original story of Eve
who's literally having to fight Panthers
in the beginning of the human race is
now embodied in this young woman in
Brazil who's still continuing to fight
and move forward and to make progress
and to make the world a better place for
the next generation okay so then it's
gonna go through some of these origins
like fire and hunting gathering and
agriculture and civilizations and also
on a like
to make the world better um so those are
the next episodes I'm talking about what
I have next for to complete the prologue
because the prologue still isn't
complete yet this is the ones that we
just said those were the next episodes
and then so the prologue completing is
what you described with going on the
journey from the very beginning what we
see we interact with with the different
maps then we skip the the data
visualization of two migrations the
first migration out of Africa with
people walking the second forced
migration across the Atlantic as we go
across the Atlantic who you realize that
Eve is somebody who's been taken from
Africa and she's going to the other side
and then we land boom in present-day
Brazil and we realized that he was alive
in this young woman in Brazil today oh
whoa okay okay I'm following now okay oh
wow okay that's a huge jump because that
goes yeah that goes like like a hundred
thousand years forward like really
quickly yeah yeah and that's another
beauty of his technology being able to
compress time so that people can
perceive of actually being able to
connect the dots so easily and then
being able to come back and you know get
to the next part of the story and then
connect the dots to how that's affecting
us now here today and that's how I kind
of see the structure of this being
because like if you really think about
any any given topic like you know that
the thread runs all the way through it
and there's all these things that are
happening along the way but it's like
it's the same kind of thread so like how
can we how can we move people through
that thread effectively so they can see
how you know all of the factors that
contribute to who you are sitting here
and Who I am sitting here are actually
connected to all these things that
happen hundreds of thousands of years
ago yeah interesting so you think every
one of them is gonna be like a
compressed time like you're going from a
hundred thousand years to now like in
terms of like fire or agriculture or
whatever it may be so the beauty of this
project being episodic is um first of
all we're at the very beginning of
storytelling in this medium so I'm one
of the people who's laying down the
groundwork for what it's actually going
to look like and what it's going to be
and it's I know for a fact that it's
going to continue to evolve as our
sensibilities evolve as what I'm
building continues to grow and as that
it continues to evolve as well so
whether it's going to continue along the
same path of compressing time along data
visualizations or whether there will be
some sort of new way that'll make sense
for episode one and then a new way
that'll make sense for episode two and
or even if by that place authority a
complete by that point it's a completely
filled out fleshed out world where the
narrative itself is something that's
constantly evolving and changing with AI
that's we're very early on it's it's
this is where it is right now yeah you
know damn we're super excited for the
continuation of the project holy cow
okay let's um let's ask you a couple
questions that we like asking the guests
on the way out of the show okay okay all
right one of the questions that we like
asking is what do you think happens
before we're born and what do you think
happens after we die
to that I order spawn we're never born
and we never die teach us more the idea
of birth is a beginning so in that sense
of birth I would say that we have no
beginning and also that we have no end
so we go through the experience of
thinking we have a beginning and
thinking that we have an end and then we
realize we're infinite and then we think
that it began and then we think that it
ended and then we realized we're
infinite and it's a constant cycle until
we decide that we want to stop going
through the idea of thinking that we
began who thinking that we ended and we
just want to stay infinite aside and
then do you think we're alone in the
cosmos I think it would be a statistical
impossibility for us to be alone in the
cosmos I think that anybody who thinks
that we are has probably never gone to a
place with high elevation and nope light
pollution and looked at just how many
stars are in the sky and then stop to
think about the fact that those are all
those stars that they're looking at are
only in our galaxy and that our galaxy
is just one of an infinite number of
galaxies in an infinitely large universe
that's can getting bigger every minute
every second it's getting bigger and if
you actually just think about that for
sheer numbers it would make absolutely
no sense whatsoever to think that we are
alone in the universe it would make no
sense to think that we're even alone in
the galaxy do you think we're in a
simulation
yes I think that I think that that what
I talked about the simulation begins
when we think that we began but what we
really are is a collective consciousness
that is decided to break off into these
individual fractions because we want to
experience what it's like to experience
our self and we want to collect
experience so that we can know ourselves
better but I think that what we truly
are is one collective everything and I
think that that's also kind of at the
core of what I'm doing with my project
as well so the infinite consciousness
Blake's off into the self that gets to
have the experiences to better
understand itself itself yes
I love it and then how about what is the
most beautiful thing in the world love
but love is really the only thing in the
world and everything else is an illusion
[Applause]
ah thanks sure thank you thanks for
coming out of the show this is good
super fun thank you for having me
we really appreciate it we're really
excited for all your work let's go back
that should thank you great job so far
it's been so wonderful learning from you
thank you we would love for everyone to
give us your thoughts in the comments
below on the episode we would also love
for you to check out the links in the
bio to charities patreon also go back
fetch it calm as well as the Twitter
profile go and talk to more people your
friends your family and co-workers
people online on social media about the
origins of humanity and technology have
more conversations about it gain better
wisdom about it build projects using
these new technologies that we have
around these subjects few shout out to
Ron Vargas for producing and directing
thank you very much Ron and support the
artists the entrepreneurs do communities
the organizations around the world that
you believe in support them support
charity support simulation our links are
below help us grow and prosper and go
and build the future everyone manifest
your dreams into the world thank you so
much for tuning in and we will see you
soon
[Music]
[Music]